[Music]
the grammy's coming to las vegas it is
this sunday and there is one band in
particular that has the whole town
country world buzzing with excitement
talking about bts and we sent christian
casadas to look into why this boy band
is such a big focus right now christian
what'd you learn that's right brian and
denise well let me tell you i talked to
several fans about bts coming to las
vegas and i'm not going to lie after a
few minutes of screaming well they tell
us it's all about the music they say the
group has been able to achieve a level
of success not many are able to get
las vegas is about to turn into bts city
as fans flock from all over i am
generally a k-pop fan i've always
enjoyed korean pop music i am korean
melody lee can't stop smiling after
learning that k-pop band bts is coming
along with a tsunami of themed events
this is definitely
not expected i think for even us fans
like we didn't expect them to take over
the entire city
[Music]
the seven-member boy band has been
around for over a decade but their las
vegas fan base will be put to the
ultimate test as they make their first
appearance at sunday's grammy awards at
mgm grand socal resident desiree
gonzalez just became part of the group's
40 million fan base known as bts army
they have an ability to like jump from
different music styles around the valley
themed events are expected to pop up to
give music fans a chance to come
together i've already rsvp to the uh
photo exhibit at area 15. and then
there's the cafe at mandalay bay so i
have a reservation for that and i want
to see the water
show at the bellagio because i've never
seen it both fans say their highlight
will be attending the band's sold out
concert at allegion stadium i'm going to
all four here in las vegas i'm very
excited
[Music]
four concerts all right according to the
band's talent agency the themed events
begin next week as they transform las
vegas into what they call a concert play
park christian casa is live local now
so exciting all right again the grammys
are coming up this sunday they'll be
live from the mgm grand garden arena
they start at five o'clock until 8 30.
now we're going to be airing them right
here on channel 8 and